I was reading recently that you have
been meditating with members of Congress
I've tried it I'm not good at it but you
really have to commit to quieting your
mind and being honest with yourself do
you think just knowing what you know
what any of us know about Donald Trump
would he be someone who could benefit
from meditation some people are beyond
hope
if if you have a normal nervous system
you can anyone yeah I you know I said
it's funny you say that it got a huge
laugh but I think you are right I don't
think he has the kind of mind that could
sit down and be the kind of mind I can I
can see him I'm focusing on my breathing
its world class breathing when you play
the kind of mind yeah yeah assuming yes
that is a mine yes yes so you're a fan
is what you're saying Trump 2016 is your
mantra okay so he's not gonna be a
fanatic to be a fan yeah you you have to
you also have have said that you believe
that it is time for a female president
and why are you just taking Hillary
Clinton out of the equation or Carly
Fiorina why do you think a female should
be president right now is there do they
have special qualities that we need at
this moment yes we need to move from
survival of the fittest to survival of
the wisest and enjoy you know as part of
our evolution it was fine to have male
leaders because they went out for the
hunt they learned how to kill their
two-month rise in their mind it will
kill it
[Applause]
I don't remember seeing that on the dime
[Music]
women on the other than hell you can't
just talk that way I don't know what
kind of men you've been dealing with but
yeah you're right women have a sense for
beauty intuition nurturing affection
tenderness wisdom it's not like how can
I beat you and get the best out for
myself right I think the feminine
architect whether it's the mother or
it's Athena the wisdom sexuality beauty
healer these are very much needed in our
society today
[Applause]